is love truly blind Amber's blonde now I
gotta acknowledge she's looking great
I'm loving it I'm loving it what a
rottweil derived this show has been I
mean how excited are you guys to finally
share the ending with the world I
honestly forgot that it was coming out
it's been half a year and a half has
been nice so it's not an easy thing to
keep such a big big secret hi hey I
didn't know you're in here
how do you guys think the pods like
helped or hurt air connection I mean I
don't know about other people I do think
that the The Situation's a pod and the
intent behind it because everybody was
so serious about like relationships and
trying to find love it was easier for us
from behind a wall to be able to you
know get down to the nitty-gritty of
what we wanted from a relationship and
that's not something that you can do on
an everyday date it's it's hard it's
hard to talk to that or to someone
especially someone who looks like her
you know like face to face about things
that aren't you know very shallow you
know alright it's it's it makes a lot of
use thing in the pod it's made it a lot
easier to you know really connect I
think on a deeper level
were there questions you guys weren't
allowed to ask like weight height and
race anything like that I think so you
could have asked whatever you wanted to
there were really no guidelines for
things that were taboo to say it's just
that I think the point of the experiment
was to avoid trying to figure out what
people look like because that might have
led you and to you know the same
mistakes that you the same shell and
mistakes that you'd made in dating
before so I tried not to ask but when
somebody you know you asked about
somebody's hobbies and what they did as
a kid and they say I'm a baseball player
you can't help but physically kind of
grasp an idea of what they look like and
it was actually one of the other girls
were the ones that told me how tall you
were because I had no idea how did you
guys feel that you were portrayed on the
show where you overall happy
with it or you know were there things
you wish were explained that weren't I
think because it was just ten episodes
it was really hard to cut it down and I
know Matt and I like individually just
as far as we're concerned we both have
really big personalities so I think it
was easy for a lot of people to miss
things about our personality so it was a
very limited perspective about what
people were seeing of us yeah I feel
like a lot of the like the like we're
both very jokey
we both love having fun and I think that
that a lot of that got missed at least
so yeah I think well it's so it was just
shortly there such short episodes it's
hard to see and catch all of the the
serious conversations that we had about
you know our future life and our
interests and hopes and dreams etc and I
think because of a lot of that they see
such a smaller such such a smaller
perspective of that if I were to if I
were to go back I wish they would have
shown a lot more of our our pod times
because I feel like the one thing that
they missed is the Y like showing why we
had the connections we had because I
feel like I know that I came out having
three connections pretty strong
connections and I feel like nobody
really understood why that was so one of
those connections being Jessica who I
think is getting the most flak from the
internet now that you're watching the
show how do you guys feel about all the
criticism that she's getting and do you
think it's valid
I don't so when we okay here when we
were filming I didn't know any like I
didn't know that we had any issues
basically like I think it kind of we
were kind in our own little world me and
me and amber work and so they weren't
really focused on other people's
relationships that much we're really
focusing like I know that Amber to talk
to mark a couple times and I
couple conversation - Jessica obviously
as you saw but I never thought of it as
anything other than like a like a
friendly conversation like we were
friends because we did have a you know
pretty strong friendship started in the
pods and so yeah I don't know I don't
know necessarily if she is there's all
the flack or anything like that but yeah
I really talked to her since since the
show ended there since filming ended so
I don't know amber what did you make of
the one-on-one conversation that Barnett
and Jessica had looking back it's
hilarious because a lot of people were
saying lad you'd really held your cool
when she was going herself at your
fiancee and I'm like you know I had no
idea because what she was saying to
Burnett like oh my god I would never
like that's what I was hearing so when
we were in the pods something you guys
didn't get a chance to see was on the
girl side there was a lot of like really
female centric like girl power like we
were all super supportive of each other
and understanding of the experiment and
really trying to be there for each other
through what we were going through and
be honest with each other so for
instance Elsie and I were both really
honest with each other and like
supportive that we both had feelings for
Barnet at the time and because we
respected each other like we kept our
distance and like we didn't want to hear
about each other's dates we didn't want
to hurt each other's feelings
so who to see that Jessica was coming
out of left field like planning it as
shady as she was I was really offended
that she disrespected me in that way
when I thought that we had a rapport I
thought we were at least some type of
friends like I had no idea I thought
maybe she had a crush on him which I was
trying to be understanding of yeah but
um you know it's it's a process and it
was an experiment and for anybody that
was on the show I think we were all just
trying to learn from it and grow from it
and and I really hope she grows from
that like a lot of growing can be done
now you guys are you guys are be
watching the show at this point right or
are you like I can't watch myself on
screen here are a couple parts that I
like to read
I think some of it's just not super fun
to watch and it's less about our
personal interactions and more about
knowing how people are perceiving you
know these special moments for us and
they're seeing things in the wrong way
so right what's been the most difficult
thing for you guys to to relive or is
there something people keep saying
online you're like I'm gonna clear the
air about this oh the finances yeah
the finances I think people absolutely
got the wrong idea because they were
there was limited conversation that they
were able to be privy to as far as the
debt that I had at the time Matt also
had student loans and he had credit
cards that he was paying on etc and I
hadn't been paying on my student loans
because as previously mentioned after my
abortion and I fallen into a depression
and I dropped out of school so you know
my mental health was more of a priority
for me and you know I was slowly
building my life back together when I
got the opportunity to be on the show
and I think people have extremely like
just completely missed the fact that I
was working on bettering myself not
expecting somebody else to make me
better Matt and I were and always had
agreed to be in a partnership where we
both put in work and bills together and
the stay-at-home mom thing is a goal not
an expectation and there were a lot of
people saying that I expect that as an
easy way out and I don't know if you
guys have met this man but if he has
children they are gonna be more than two
candles yeah so not an easy job I'm
undertaking here we just found out you
guys are doing a reunion every Union is
happening so have you guys film that yet
and what could what can you tease about
what to expect
I think the reunion will be interesting
for everybody to see fun times
I know I personally got closure from
that so taking from that what you will
hmm-hmm I got closer to summit hold that
[Music]